Man 1: The second paragraph
of the declaration
is one of the most amazing
set of phrases ever written.
It is the creed of what
makes America and now,
what makes the aspirations of many people
around the world.
Let's just read that first sentence
of the second paragraph,
which is just awesome.
It's, "We hold these
truths to be self-evident
"that all men are created
equal, that they are endowed
"by their Creator with
certain unalienable Rights,
"that among these are Life,
Liberty, and the pursuit
"of Happiness."
Man 2: "All men are created
equal, that they are endowed
"by their Creator with
certain unalienable Rights,
that among these are Life,
Liberty, and the pursuit
"of Happiness."
Let's start even with the word "we".
Who's "we"?
"We", it says, is the American
colonies, now gathering
as the United States of
America, but they're basically
white males.
Everybody at that
convention is a white male,
most of them landowners.
So, what the arc of American history shows
is that word "we" begins,
over the course of decades
and then centuries, to
include more and more people.
Eventually, it includes freed slaves,
eventually it includes
women, but that's a narrative
of American history, is who are we
that have these truths as self-evident,
that we're all equal?
Now, it's also interesting,
the phrase "self-evident".
This is something that
comes from the rationality
of the scientific era we were in.
This is an age right after
Isaac Newton has made
everything in the universe rational
through scientific laws
and it also comes from some
of the philosophers,
especially David Hume,
that there are just certain
things that are self-evident.
That's an important concept,
that they're not appealing
to anybody else to say,
"What are these truths?"
They're saying, "This is
just our rationality tells us
"this is true," but then they say,
"all men are created equal."
Now, they say men.
Back then, men was supposed to be a phrase
that was more inclusive than just males.
Man 2: For man.
Man 1: Right, it's like
mankind, to some extent,
but then again, at least
Jefferson, he owned slaves.
Women, they weren't necessarily
given the right to vote.
Even though they mean
"man" sort of like mankind,
they also really generally
mean men, at this point.
Once again, this is where the
American narrative starts.
Fortunately, that phrase
gets expanded over time
as to what they mean.
Man 2: Right.
Man 1: Look at the phrase "created equal".
What does that really mean?
First of all, it doesn't mean
that people are always equal.
At a certain point in life,
Jefferson owns a whole lot
of property and Franklin
is quite rich as a printer
and different people have
different statuses in life,
but they're saying that in a
fundamental, political way,
we all start off created equal.
We have certain rights that
you just can't take away
from us whether we're
rich or poor or whatever.
Those unalienable rights
are Life, Liberty,
and the pursuit of Happiness.
Man 2: I'm guessing it's
also a ding at the King,
because royalty ...
One underlying assumption
is that it's inherited
and that you are created better off.
Man 1: Right and Thomas Paine,
who is a pamphleteer, has
just written this document
Common Sense and that's
helped inspire everybody.
At the heart of the document Common Sense
is that there's no divine right of kings.
Divine right of kings
was a British concept,
which meant God made
certain people more equal
or better than others, and
the king, by divine right,
had these powers and we're
saying, "No, the kings don't
"have any more powers."
Ben Franklin was very much of that way,
which was he hated the
notion of aristocracy,
that some people were
born noble and some people
were born aristocratic and
some people were born royal
and whatever, but think
about it for a moment.
What was Thomas Jefferson thinking?
A guy who owns a lot of
slaves, what was he thinking
when he writes this amazing phrase,
"all men are created equal"?
I think he was very conflicted.
Here's a guy who did
not end up even freeing
most of his slaves in his
lifetime and yet, he could write
these inspiring words.
If you read about
Jefferson, you know that was
the fundamental conflict
and it's a conflict that we,
as a nation, have been wrestling with.
Man 2: As a slaveowner, he
also knew them very well.
He knew them as human beings, perhaps.
Man 1: Right, well he fathered children
with one of the slaves.
Ben Franklin is interesting,
because early on in life,
he had two household slaves,
who he didn't really treat
as slaves, but they were
his household servants
and he had allowed the
advertising of slavery
in the Pennsylvania Gazette, the newspaper
that he published, but he
realized, after he writes
these words, "created equal",
he realizes how abhorrent
that is, to his own notions,
that people are created equal.
Of course, he's by then, freed his slaves,
but becomes a president of
the Society for the Abolition
of Slavery in Pennsylvania,
as a way of trying
to make up for the fact that he'd erred,
he had been wrong when he was young,
to tolerate the institution
of slavery and he becomes
an abolitionist.
Of course, John Adams,
from the very beginning,
was an abolitionist.
Man 2: This is important
for people to realize.
When you take an American history class,
it seems like obviously
everything comes to a head
leading up the Civil War,
but this was already starting
to become an issue, a moral issue,
a philosophical issue,
even at the founding
of the country.
Man 1: And a political issue, as well,
because if you want Jefferson
and you want Virginia in,
the reason John Adams ...
He was a great abolitionist,
but there were no plantations.
There was no cotton being
grown in Massachusetts,
but if you were a cotton
farmer or a plantation owner
in Virginia, you tended to
own slaves and it becomes
a great political issue
where the slaveholding states
have to be brought into this union.
We see that conflict when
the constitution is written
11 years later.
They're still having this
conflict on what do we do
about slavery?
Man 2: Yeah and it will continue
for another 70-something years.
Man 1: Yeah, if you want to say
that it was totally
resolved by the Civil War
and there will be some who will say that
that was the original stain on
this unbelievably beautiful phrase,
which is that "all men are created equal."
Man 2: Yeah, very cool.